welcome I'm Alexander Rose the director
of the long now foundation and normally
we do a thing called along short or a
short movie that exemplifies long term
thinking but since this in the last two
weeks we've been working with News Trust
and Kirk citron who's been running our
project or a project with us called long
news news that matters over a long
period of time we thought we'd have them
to a quick presentation the last two
weeks in a new sense on the future of
energy and I'll have them give you a
brief on what long news is and news
trust and how we've been working
together and then we'll pass it over to
Ed thank you good evening I'm Kirk
citron and I'm an associate and an
editor at the long now foundation and
this is Florin executive director of
news trust and we're gonna briefly tell
you about this week's energy news hunt
but first some background we've been
running a project called the long news
which as alexander said looks for news
stories that might still matter fifty or
a hundred or ten thousand years from now
and just to give you an idea of a couple
of themes of the kinds of things we've
been looking at over the last couple
months there's talk that there may be
another mass extinction event but the
problem this time is an asteroid or
volcanic eruption it's us and we found
headlines like more than 800 wildlife
species are now extinct and may be a
reason we should care which is that
animal biodiversity keeps people healthy
a second area another theme is the
extension of human lifespans with
stories like it's starting to get
crowded in the hundred years olds Club
and half of us babies living today may
reach a hundred so that's a flavor of
the kinds of news stories that we're
looking for that might have some kind of
long-term significance and lately for
obvious reasons we've been thinking
about the future of energy kind of
hoping that the current crisis will
prompt a deeper conversation about the
need to find alternatives to oil like
fusion which we're going to be hearing
about tonight and so to do that we've
partnered with news trusts to do this
energy news on
I will turn it over to Brees now to tell
you more about that Thank You Kirk news
trust is a community of citizens that
care about good journalism because we
need it to make informed decisions as
citizens and so we rate the news for
quality and we feature some of the best
stories that we find every day on our
site and we offer a hybrid news filter
which engages professionals amateurs and
computers to filter the news and this
Holy Trinity and collaborative approach
is an effective way to find good
journalism all in one place and it
manifests itself on the home page of our
site news trust Nets every day our
editors feature stories worth reading on
topics like in this case the future of
energy but you can also see our
reviewers at the bottom of the screen
and they're doing the reviewing which
helps us feature the day's top stories
based on their reviews and ratings and
those are filtered by computer
algorithms so this week we're hosting an
energy news hunt and we hope that you
will join us it works a little bit like
a scavenger hunt we're all looking for
good journalism about the future of
energy so each day our editors post
stories on our site and we invite you to
review them so when you click a story on
our site you go to the news providers
website and you can see our review form
in the top right corner and what we ask
you to do is read the story then click
on the buttons that describe it best is
it factual as it fairs at well-sourced
we have other criteria and based on your
answers were able to surface some of the
more interesting stories so what kind of
stories have we been finding a past week
we look at stories about solar we found
some great articles from their Spiegel
and climate biz again mainstream sources
and dependent sources we've looked at
nuclear power with stories like these
the case for and against nuclear power
from The Wall Street Journal
and great insights from other
publications like spiked as far as the
wind power
again interesting stories from UPI
popular science and many more and the
topic of today's talk
Fusion Energi again coverage ranges from
the BBC to the New Scientist and it's a
diversity of all these sources that
really makes it interesting that we can
actually see how the different sources
cover the same topics and we've reviewed
hundreds of stories already the next
week we'll share the best and worst
coverage on both the news trust and the
long now blogs and we'll keep adding
stories on our site so we hope you'll
join us and the best way for you to do
that is to go to news trust duck dot
long now dot org and we hope to see you
online thank you very much thanks thanks
for bass I'm Stewart Brand it's a little
continuity here for briefs Florin was at
the hackers conference in 1983 and made
a video of it that's still available
online this is an event that Kevin Kelly
and my wife ran feeling and I organized
back and basically the Bronze Age of
computer them and what's interesting is
you'll see people there like Richard
Stallman and others who were young
pioneers at the time we're all still
very active but the stuff you see them
playing with looks like you know alien
hand ax level of technology what's going
on across the bay and over the hill at
Livermore is a search inside the star
power stars are powered by fusion and
we've been looking for productive ways
to bring that power here and Alexander
rose and I went to the National Ignition
facility a couple months ago and it
knocked our socks off basically
everybody who sees that goes oh my god
one this is amazing anyhow to do that
massive kind of stuff with lasers but it
might mean
very good things
so we can't all go to the National
Ignition facility so what Alexander and
I decided is maybe we could bring the
National Examination the facility here
and then the person of Ed Moses and his
presentation here it is
thank you so much to invite me here and
all of you for coming out I'm gonna be
talking about laser fusion energy and
what that means and the future of it and
it's gonna be at the the story of the
National Ignition facility and that's
actually a picture of the National
Ignition facility transported to San
Francisco yeah now I when I go around
the world I transported to Tokyo or
Paris or wherever I have to be and that
happened to me and that's sort of the
point you know my purpose is to show you
you know by the end of the day you know
by the end of this evening that it is
possible in the fairly near future you
know what we're doing at the NIF as the
National Ignition facility is called
gonna be a part of your future a clean
energy future and you know we want to
demonstrate the route to fusion energy
and fusion energy is so cool is because
as Stewart said not only does the power
the Stars but we use the hydrogen in
water there's lots of it and it has an
energy density about seven million times
that of normal chemical bonds that's
nice and also no carbon right
you're burning hydrogen so let's we'll
be talking about that you know not all
of you can come out but you know we do
have public affairs tours and Linda
Seaver is here from the lab and you know
it is possible to come out to the lab if
you make arrangements and to see it and
it's uh it's so this is an interesting
picture I'll show you how it used to
look 40 years ago you know in a second
but this is where the NIF is it's you
know 60 kilometers away and it's out in
Livermore it used to be out ranch land
but slowly but surely we've been
swallowed by San Francisco okay so since
I'm at the long now foundation
I've been thinking about you know
recasting history so this is the history
of the universe
and the future of the universe and the
history of the universe goes back
approximately fourteen billion years
which is a long time so if we looking
back in time on this log scale
you know if ten years ago a hundred
years ago a thousand years ago ten
thousand etc you can see a work our way
back to 10 billion 14 billion years ago
the time of the Big Bang and we can look
forward to long now view of the world
this can we look forward ten thousand
years now there's another way to date
these things you know which is 2020
21:10 thirty one ten twelve thousand one
hundred and ten when you think about
this or go back ten thousand years to
eight that - eight thousand which is you
know a little bit before BC and you can
see because there's a log scale things
get crunched up but I think it's sort of
an important point well we're looking
that forward is ten thousand years can
we imagine that think about what our
ancestors who are coming into
agriculture and forming the first
villages and cities so could possibly
think about us today now that's the I
think the dynamic of the challenge that
we think about when we think about our
responsibility for the future so here
are the four stages of the universe from
from the you know human centric point of
view you know there was this ten billion
years of pre-earth right and you know
about five billion years ago there was a
supernova around this part of the Milky
Way it blew up but starred us everywhere
which we are now made of right and the
earth was made out of and then we had
earth and almost immediately there was
life on Earth and then we had the life
on Earth stage which is still going on
but before us we sort of had about four
billion years of life without us and
then we have this hundred thousand years
or so of human civilization the human
civilization I define as when we came
out of Africa right you know Homo
sapiens was established
we started roaming the earth and now
we're looking at the long now vision
now what happened during these times you
know we had this very nice period of
around 4 billion years where there was
hydrocarbon and oxygen production so all
the critters that came before us were
hard at work you know you know Burt
making hydrocarbons CH bonds which were
now thinking about very carefully and
making oxygen so we could breathe in the
times there was a lot of oxygen and when
that happened there was explosions of
carbon making carbon to carbon making
and when there was not there wasn't so
much but that was that period
what is this period about human
civilization is hydro carbon and oxygen
burning so we did that for a few billion
years we came around now we're starting
to we started to harvest that and what
this leads to now the situation that
we're this precipice were on
environmental disaster because of this
burning or do we find a way to have a
clean energy future so that's the
history of the universe's and four steps
there wasn't the earth there was you
know we've made car hydrocarbons and
oxygen then we started burning it now
we're here today what are we gonna do
this is the problem now if you look only
back ten thousand years you know
everything seemed fine you know until
the last couple of hundred years right
where the population of the earth made
this incredible change in slope and it
made this change in slope because of
carbon right the industrial revolution
happened right and actually so you can
think about is James Watt then Louis
Pasteur came around and figured out
healthcare you know then there are
things like that a few great men and a
few great women who did great things but
they led to us learning to procreate
there was the Green Revolution and go
from you know hundreds of millions to
billions in a couple of hundred years
and this is has changed things
dramatically in fact if you just look at
the United States you know these are
quadrillion btus if you don't know what
they are it's okay just a measure of how
much energy we use from the 1850s to
today we've gone from barely using
energy
to three trillion watts now go over
three trillion watts you know you know
for those of you who are mathematically
I'm supposed to stay in the light so
I'll move back here three trillion watts
you know that's three times ten to the
twelve watts right and there's three
times ten to the eighth of us that's ten
thousand watts each so we you know all
of us are using a hundred 100 watt light
bulbs all the time that's not including
eating that's the energy that we are
pretty we are consuming as Americans
right now and how do we do this again go
back 150 years you know remember we are
the carbon burners right so you know 150
years ago we were basically a wood
society but after a while we would chop
down the forest we went over to coal
right and then we went to oil and then
we went to gas and then we finally did a
little dam building and collecting hydro
energy and then we did nuclear and then
you see this incredible little
renewables right right and I think this
is a really interesting chart and I want
to show you some things about it that
you that will be useful to understand
our future because if the past is
prologue this tells you something it
takes a long time to change energy
modalities you know takes about 50 years
to for coal to displace wood and it sort
of took that amount of time for oil to
displace coal but you see it didn't
displace all of it and then it took you
know another 40 years for natural gas to
displace some of the oil it didn't
displace any of the coal oh and then we
had nuclear sort of displaced some of
the gas but none of the oil or the coal
right so what happens is you have these
modalities lasts for a long time and
they increasingly or get harder and
harder to displace previous types of
energy burning and the reason that is is
because you spend all that money to
build that and they generally last 50 to
70 years and once you've done that you
don't want to throw it out and in fact
you know you know your ratepayers
whoever you were during that time say no
I'm happy with this I spent my money
let's use it this is really the amazing
or you know in 1900 we were a 98% carbon
burning society and today a hundred
years later we've gone all the way to
ninety percent so if anyone thinks we're
not a carbon burning society you know
and and sort of really entrenched in it
look at this you know we know that our
energy supply is this this is what we're
doing this is you know a gas flame out
right and what we have here is the
following thing that we have to look at
what is the problem with fossil fuels
well you know going back
you know those billion or two billion
years we were burning up about a ten
million years of hydrocarbons every year
some people say twenty million you know
it's sort of hard to measure and that
means it's not gonna last forever
so we might have a hundred years to go
of coal you know forty years to go of
oil these things are argued but it's not
200 or 300 this is sort of where we are
right so it's not gonna last forever
maybe that's good you know fossil fuel
can affect the quality of our life this
is a famous picture you know of the
bird's nest and Pei King on a clear day
right right it's a it's this is old
pollution or old la pollution and fossil
fuel can lead to environmental disaster
everyone knows this picture you know
what I think is amazing about this
picture you know what's going on in the
Gulf of Mexico there's a 30-inch hole in
the bottom out a mile down in the Gulf
that has that's putting that around
something like 50,000 barrels a day
which is a million barrels you know
every three weeks or so sounds like a
huge number right but just remember the
United States is burning a million
barrels of oil an hour right so you
think of that right and then you think
about what's really going on you know in
our world this focuses our attention it
has taken President Obama's whole agenda
off the table right this is where he's
at right now and that shows the unseen
stability of the system that we're
living in and the other thing that
fossil fuels can do it can affect the
climate
this is argued by some that it isn't
exactly affecting the climate yet or
maybe have some smaller effect or
unknown effect or how it will develop
over the over the next 50 years you know
but I think the preponderance of
scientists sort of have taking the point
of view that it is very likely that this
is an effect that is real and over the
next 10 years it'll be sorted out and
you know science is slow and coming to
conclusions usually and it's deliberate
I think this debate has been going on
for a while but it's I think it's
obvious what's happening now I don't
mean Katrina was caused by global
climate warming but there are many
things that are and the way I think
about it and I know you many of you have
probably had this thoughts many times
for the first time humankind is acting
as a force of nature right and I don't
mean that we're doing agriculture or
things like that or dragging you know
species around the globe in ways that
are unnatural right now we're in a place
we're acting like a force of nature
globally and this is I think something
that's kind of a first you know we've
always been a local locally driven
species so but what one group of people
were doing and what another group of
people were doing was not affecting
everyone they could be localized you
know and now we're I like to say we're
not in a global society we're in a
non-local society which is a has a
slight subtle difference to me you know
we can think we're acting locally and
remember all politics is local but we're
having effects on each other and when
you look at this picture some people
look at Greenland and they say you know
that's a big ice sheet seems to be
melting faster than people thought right
you know the ocean that seems to be
rising you know the amount of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere is going up
what the temperature is doing or not
doing is really hard to tell on short
time periods but over long time periods
is going up and how is this going to
affect us well let's go back to the u.s.
you know if you go back to the US the
way it's going to affect us it's really
hard to get out of this carbon habit
because in 1970 or so you can see
everything frozen right so
were sort of 95 90 percent carbon then
and that's where we are now and those
modalities take forever to change so
what do you think we're gonna do this is
the fingerprint of the human kind right
at how its dealing with us this is the
the earth at night I think what's
interesting about the earth at night is
how interesting you can see where we
live but it's also interesting it
doesn't quantitatively tell you what's
happening China looks bright India looks
bright but remember they're using around
10% per capita energy that we are and
they don't like that and why should they
they want to live at our standard of
living and they are right they're
raising their level of energy use
rapidly and there's gonna be about 3
billion more people you know sailing on
this earth with us and the amount of
energy we need is gonna go up now
whether it's 2 billion or 4 billion
which is also our key we're six and a
half billion right now some people will
go to eight and a half evils 10 10 I
don't know what it is it's a lot you
know
remember China is sort of a billion
billion - if it's 2 and 1/2 billion its
to China's right it's 3 and a half
billion 3 chives it's a lot of people
and they're happening to us pretty
quickly so we are at a tipping point on
where we're going
you know the climate is changing we're
running out of carbon it's affecting the
way we live what are we gonna do this is
something else that's happening you know
if you look at the United States only
were now remember we stopped building in
the 70s and 80s we're gonna have said we
have 70 year infrastructure it's gonna
turn off or run out by 2050 2060 and
while it's going off the electricity
demand is going to go up it's going our
for two reasons even with conservation
and even with an efficiency we are
becoming a more electrical society and
we're using more electricity so that
combination shows that the demand is
growing for electricity and our
electrical infrastructure is going away
so there's this big gap that's forming
and this gap is kind of interesting and
if you look at this
you can see that we need around 250
gigawatts by 2050 so dessert that
everybody know what a gigawatt is so a
nuclear reactor is a gigawatt you know
Moss Landing everyone knows on the way
down to the aquarium 500 megawatts so
you need the United States needs but you
can't build more slanting that's gas the
United States needs something like 200
or so Diablo canyons by 2050 or some
other green source of energy and it gets
worse and worse after that so 2030 2050
is where things happen and that's our
challenge if you look at the earth you
know all worldwide not to beat this to
death it sort of gets worse you know
this and now I show this in billions of
barrels of oil equivalent I show you
these units so you just you know when
you're working and they're walking
around you see this here's where we are
today it's a fossil fuel society this is
what we think we have to do you know
most models agree not exactly in order
to stay at two degrees centigrade in
which people forget is 4 degrees
fahrenheit on average above where we are
today and as a scientist you know I just
have to say nor as a social scientist if
I were one you know turning that around
you know based on our history it's an
incredibly difficult past you know it's
in fact if you look at this this says by
2050 60 we should go back to
pre-industrial revolution carbon
emissions how do you do it it's real
hard so not only that we have to make a
huge amount of low-carbon energy in the
end of the century and this is all going
to happen in 2030 to 2050 only 20 years
from now ha and you know the problem is
we talked about that that lag timer
inertia in the system if we decide to
good ideas today it's gonna be hard to
pull this off one more thing that makes
this even more difficult we are
concentrating in two cities you know
right now this is the
this is the megacity look in 2000 mega
cities or cities above a population of
10 million this is how people think it's
gonna look in 25 right there there you
can see it that's exploding cities why
do people go to cities that's where the
jobs are you know that's where culture
is you know that's where centers of
power are and by the way they're more
energy efficient
you know cities are the most energy
efficient parts of our society this is
where people are going and you know
because they're in cities they need
baseload power we don't want to have
power that goes on and off you know
based on whether the wind is blowing or
the Sun is out you know we live in a
24-hour Society so we need energy that's
affordable clean non geopolitical that's
a big deal we don't like depending on
other people no one likes depending on
of the people for where they get their
energy we'd like it to be inexhaustible
we'd like it to be non proliferate fit
into a physical infrastructure that we
have right you know that means you want
to be able to plug into where you are
compact and acceptable to all culture
and deliverable and timely that's a
quite a list you know and most people
when they look at that list say well I
don't know what to do or I have everyone
has their own idea what to do and
everyone become sort of zealots about
their particular idea you know China
worked on population control and sort of
helped on some levels you know some
people say people shouldn't develop you
know they should live in a you know less
developed society other people say we
should renewables like wind or Sun or
Sawgrass you know or we have nuclear or
we have carbon sequestration take the
carbon out of our carbon producing
plants or we could be more energy
efficient all of these are clearly a
part of our infrastructure of our future
but none of them is a panacea you know
at least most people don't think so so
then I ask you what did I come here is
there another idea right one that could
be really exciting and the answer is and
I love this picture that's a picture of
the Sun what I love more about it is the
picture of the
you know the US Space Station flying
across the Sun and you know cuz I think
it sort of says man's capabilities for
good or you know good or maybe I think
it's a little bit too much but it shows
you know we're not limited in our vision
if we choose to and I think the answer
is right in front of us you know just
look at where we are you know look at
the Sun in fact look anywhere in the
universe in our cosmos and you come up
to and this is this beautiful picture
out of the Hubble you know and we're
looking from hundreds of thousands to
billions of years away in this picture
billions of light-years away and you say
that fusion powers the cosmos so every
bit of light that you see in the day sky
or the night sky every bit is coming
from burning plasmas right or fusion
systems and and the question is where
did that come from and that's you know
old Albert so Albert in 1905 which was
an important year for many things
besides this you know the airplane
appeared right the Wright brothers were
there Henry Ford was there this was like
an incredibly productive time for
humankind told us that the way this all
works actually he didn't quite tell us
but he pointed the way is that you know
the reason that these things this energy
is happening is you you can take mass
stuff and turn it into energy in fact he
even said more he said they're the same
thing
you know just how do you can you convert
them from one to the other and they're
measured the same and what's great about
this is see the speed of light right
it's such a big number so when you
multiply C by C you know you get a
really big number as we say
scientifically and and so a very small
amount of mass can be a very large
amount of energy if you can pull it off
now it's hard and we asked could we
build a miniature Sun on the earth and
when I talk about miniature you'll see
I'm talking about the diameter of a hair
you know I'm not talking about a big Sun
one of the reasons we like the Sun isn't
because it's far away right
you know if you know if it were like
we're if we were if we were close as
Venus's to the Sun it's sort of a warm
day right and if it's where Mars is it's
sort of cold so we're sort of in that
you know Goldilocks planet and you know
not too hot and not too cold right just
right and that is actually true and so
could we do this could we build a
miniature Sun on the earth and so what's
the recipe you know in the cookbook
right in the NIF cookbook for a fusion
on earth so we have to take hydrogen
from water you know actually just take
water and you filter out the heavy water
so at the time of the Big Bang you know
actually about one minute after the Big
Bang hydrogen appeared in the universe
and you know and there was two types of
hydrogen you know regular hydrogen and
you know and which we call hydrogen and
the other kind which is deuterium and
there's about one in seven thousand
water molecules when you go out to the
bay is heavy water and if we filter out
the heavy water and we place it in an
oven and we heat it to around two
hundred million degrees Fahrenheit you
know for a few billionths of a second
you can turn mass into copious amounts
of energy and it has no carbon and no
waste right so that's the recipe so
where do you get one of those ovens
right you know so there it is you know
that's what the National Ignition
facility is it holds an oven inside and
and and to explain how we got here we
only have to go back 50 years and this
is again a California Bay Area story
which is kind of interesting to me you
know Charlie Townes who's still at Cal
Berkeley he's 94 and still active in the
field invented or pointed the way you
know theoretically to the idea of lasers
and he did that in the in around 58 it's
a famous paper but I think more
interesting is Ted Mayman Ted Mayman
down in Malibu was working a used
aircraft where I worked at one time and
he showed the first laser and I have
actually held this laser you know and
it's and within the last two weeks it's
the 50th anniversary of the invention of
laser and it's so elegant you can
believe it you know if you look at that
sucker it's so small and it was so
revolutionary its revolution a
revolution era at the scale of the
transistor
you know people still haven't understood
that but in the next twenty or thirty
years it'll be clear that manipulating
light using lasers will have more power
or at least as much power as
manipulating electrons using
semiconductors this is a powerful device
and there's where it started and what's
really amazing this was on May 16th
1960 at around 3:00 in the afternoon at
the lab Livermore Lab three days later
and look at Livermore then right
remember that picture I showed you that
nobody used to be a naval base during
World War two and you can still see the
runway at that time John Knuckles who
was working in the nuclear weapons
program at the time realized that you
know that laser was the way to get
fusion energy you know and it started
off a 50-year journey that we are coming
to conclusion of right now so this is
what he told us to do here's the oven I
want to tell you how big it is in a
second you know we have this gold can
and we have this little ball and this
little ball has a little hydrogen in it
and there it is and it has a capsule
wall that's about I I will keep using
this a little thicker than your hair
that's made out of plastic that's rocket
fuel and what happens is okay you know
what we do is put laser light into this
oven right you can see the billionths of
a second going on and someone gets
really hot and instead of baking it red
hot like your oven does it bakes with
x-rays and it absorbed on this little
cake here and explodes and drives the
hydrogen together till it's hotter and
denser than the center of the Sun and it
burns and when it burns you actually if
you went in there and weighed that
afterwards what you can but if you did
compared to beforehand you would see
there was a little mass missing and that
mass is turned into energy for us to
harvest so how big do you think that is
anyone want to take a guess that big so
that's the oven in fact I have one right
here I don't know if you can see it all
right so that's it this is that little
gold splash there that's the full size
and that little red ball which you
unless you have Superman eyes you can't
see you know is the size of the burning
capsule right so that's a remarkable
idea that's the oven you know that's the
Betty Crocker John knuckles oven that we
have to build of course we got to build
the laser so we went off in the search
of lasers and you know in from the 70s
to the 80s we built lasers that went
from hundred joules
you know you know joules a measure of
energy to a kilojoule up by a factor of
ten to another a factor of ten to
another a factor of ten now we're up
another factor of a hundred and we're at
the National Ignition facility that
according to everything we know should
be possible to get this burn to happen
for the first time first time in the
course of human history we will have
control thermonuclear burn changing mass
energy at a scale that's just right for
making energy for our future now it does
other things too and I'll talk about
those in a second so you know takes a
long time to get you know everyone
together on doing this because there's a
very expensive facility and you know the
politicians show up and that's miss
Tyler who's you know was our
representative and now she's the
Undersecretary of state for a President
Obama and there was our groundbreaking
and then there you know that afternoon
the real people came by that's the real
groundbreaking and then you know we had
the barn-raising right so that's how
that's when the NIF was coming together
and this is how it looked inside before
we put the lasers in and I you can see
these normal-sized liver morons up here
right
so you can get the scale of this and
then it looks like that today right and
it's kind of it's kind of a great place
to be for and you know Stewart talk to
you about it when you're in it and I've
been in it a few thousand times I'm
still amazed by it you know because it's
a you know it's a masterpiece of you
know American innovation ingenuity
engineering and everything that goes
with it besides physics and this allows
us to do what we want to do and if you
look at it from it from above again you
can see the humans that's the scale of
it right now okay and each one of those
pipes has laser light in it and every
single one of them has the highest
energy laser in the world so every one
of them is higher energy than any other
laser and there's 192 of them that's why
it's so cool and by the way this is the
target chamber that we have that little
target in and I'll show you that and
this is when it was being put in place
it's 10 meters in diameter and or you
know 35 feet or so for you of the
English persuasion and and it's pure
aluminum and and this is how the
building look before we put it in and
then we slid it in carefully and that's
how it looks today almost so I want to
just show you this you know without
going out of my life these are humans
again and down here so you can see the
scale of it so we had that little target
right
we have this big ball and that's because
it puts out a lot of energy and we want
to collect it nicely and we want to have
some optical elements in there that take
care of this but it's big on one scale
but I'll show you on another scale it's
kind of small compared to what it does
so that's how it looks it actually
doesn't look this way this is the one
who's a photoshopped is really floors
here those people aren't floating and
you know we just just took them out so
you could see the whole thing at once
that's how it looks like on the inside
so there's two things I like about this
picture first of all you know how
interesting the picture is with giving
you a scale of this more important you
know this is why people work for
National Geographic if you notice this
whole picture is in focus
and you know when the photographer of
National Geographic came it was a lens
you could not believe you know and it's
kind of interesting in its own right
okay that's the target remember the
target so that's kind of interesting
that big thing we have this little
target keep this in your mind's eye
right that's how big the target is so we
have to hit that target within you know
again half the diameter of your hair and
we do it all the time so we can point at
that target and you know so now when you
will come to the NIF this is what you
see it's a nice building that's on five
hectares or twelve acres and took ten
years to build it and it shouldn't run
for the next thirty years and should do
great things for our country if your
take off the roof I love this picture
right you know and look at the CAD draw
and you can see remember if we talked
about that laser Bay here that we were
looking at or the you know that I'm
gonna just I can't see it so I'll just
stand here the target chamber is here
right that's how it looks so so what are
we gonna do with this thing let me show
you how this works
this is the real control room walking
running blender me five he's shot on the
board times three and now we're going
one over to a cartoon
that's electricity do we bring it down a
tiny bit oh yeah that's why and this is
the master oscillator room where it all
starts out it starts out at a millionth
of a billionth of the energy you have
before you get to the end and it goes
out into the laser Bay's that you saw
and goes up in its preamplifiers and it
goes up to a billion times where it
started and now you see you have this
chunk of light that's around 20 feet
long just remember in that a second of
billions of a second is how long it
takes light to travel on flight right so
that if you took a movie of this this is
actually how it would look you know the
thing that was so hard about nits was
getting it to play music
okay so this is the this is the Lego
block of NIF eight beams right now watch
would happen now we have 48 beams
that's its cousins coming along right
now we'll see another group of the
family 96 beams this isn't a 10-story
high building all these beams have to
get to get to the target at the same
time and you can see they don't look
like it but watch boom and now we turn
them from red to ultraviolet and they go
on to the target and you know the drill
now right that little target gets real
hot you know and this happens in
billions of a second
any one of a second and and when it's
getting hot
he's making an x-ray oven it's gonna
drive that target you know less than the
diameter of your air hotter than the Sun
higher pressures and what it does albert
einstein appears and says would you turn
that mass into energy and you got can
you use it and we do
I would take full credit with it for
this if I had anything to do with it but
okay so let me just tell you this is a
real picture you know except this is a
tenth of an inch this is a big tenth
that's how big that peppercorn is when
it starts and I want to show you what
happens you know graphically you know
ten billionth of a second later okay so
that's actually a picture you know again
except it's the diameter of your hair
smashing this thing together right so
when we've we've done experiments and
we're getting pretty far on this and you
know when you do stuff like this you
publish you know you have other things
in scientific journals and then we got
you know the the rolling stone of our
life is the American physical so the
bulletin of the American Physical
Society
so we got on the cover of the Rolling
Stone and you know there's a lot of
attention being paid to where we're
going right now
so this is kind of exciting so an
infusion is in the news as you heard a
little bit before and I have to say
though this is not a single laboratory
activity it's not a single discipline
activity it's multi discipline multi
laboratories academia industry and the
international community are playing a
big role in fact 49 out of 50 states you
know I'm really sorry North Dakota
didn't play but the reason is the
company in North Dakota is you know a
woman owned company and she moved to
South Dakota so we only we had North
Dakota we lost we had and didn't have
South Dakota then we ended up with South
Dakota but not North Dakota okay so you
know there's 3,000 vendor partners and
we have international partners all over
the world so this is an international
effort it's and it's been flying under
the radar screen most people don't know
about it for a long time and then we had
dedication and I gotta say this you know
when you're doing big projects and the
NIF cost around three and a half billion
dollars to put together and it took 12
years to do it you know you don't do
that on your own either you know
technically or industrially but it's a
political and a social event and you
know our California representatives the
senator senator boxer and Feinstein the
governor you know missus Tauscher
missile Lofgren and the whole the whole
crowd played a huge role
making this happen it was really a
California event but it was also a
national event and you know this is this
is the kind of dedication that we had to
making this happen and this dedication
showed how people were proud of it well
then something really important happened
you know secretary Chu otherwise known
as formally known to us as Steve Wright
you know he's a by the way he got his
Nobel Prize in laser research you know
you know it has been on a journey with
us through the NIF and he started out
kind of skeptical really because he's a
you know a brilliant scientist who's
used to tabletop work you know very high
precision work and he he'd really didn't
relate to the NIF in the beginning but
over the last five years you know he's
understood where it where it is and it's
important and he came to the lab and he
said the NIF is a marvel and believes
the NIF will achieve ignition ignition
is getting that burn to happen and we
should think about what we should do and
and he said we should start planning for
its success of what comes after it and
when he's talking about that is the
energy mission so the question is is
fusion energy a part of the solution to
this problem the global challenge you
know which i think is the existential
and fundamental challenge that we face
remember you know we have to build the
equivalent of no to do this as a species
in the 30s 40s and 50s 20 gigawatts a
week that 20 gigawatts a week is a big
number right that means you do sort of
the United States as we understand it in
six months and we have to keep doing
that this is a tremendous technical
challenge fiscal challenge and also
social social challenge so let me talk
about what our idea called laser
inertial fusion energy which is build a
laser inertial fusion engine what's what
is the NIF do and if turns laser light
into x-rays which drives that target and
that fusion happens and then we get more
energy out than we put in that's kind of
a nice idea
you have gain energy gain doesn't break
any rules of physics because you're
changing mass to energy right and you
get energy out and now you collect that
energy and you turn it into heat and you
take that heat and run it past the heat
exchanger and boil water or something
like that make Steven tournament turn a
turbine and get a generator and
electricity and then you plug into the
wall so you start out with the highest
technology but you always end up back
you know with James Watt so it isn't a
steam engine it's this very fancy steam
engine so what we have to do if you were
going to do this it was we have to add
something that converts that thermal
energy fusion energy the thermal energy
to electricity so you can see this
concept if you just use the NIF and put
that inside the system you could do that
and then what we do is turn laser light
into electrons and the electrons go
through the wires
everybody's normal wires it's nothing
different about the infrastructure and
when you do that you could change the
world if you could pull that off it's
one problem we have to do it not once
every few hours but you know ten times a
second you know that's the issue you
know it's a little bit different from an
engineering point of view then what NIF
is which is an R&D facility ten times
the second sounds like a big number but
if you multiply by 60 that's 600 rpm so
your car is going it you know I'd lean
at 600 rpm so there probably drives the
2,000 rpm it's not a big number but you
know some people are a little bit put
off by that thought but if you go to
your copy of a high-speed copy machines
and stuff like that they do that that's
not really our issue this is how it
would work this is super slow motion you
know we fire in a target literally on an
air gun or something like that and the
laser light hits it and we get ignition
and now we get out our fusion energy and
we have this salt blanket salts are good
you know not if you have high blood
pressure but salts are good generally
because neutrons have no charge right so
they sort of tend to go through things
they don't interact with you know atoms
too much they just tend to go through
they have to sort of find nuclei to bash
into and slow down but with certain
salts they have sort of these
absorptions and they really slow them
down quickly so if we have about two
feet thick of salt it'll collect the
neutrons and I'll get hot and the salt
will be molten and you know at
temperatures like 600 degrees centigrade
you know so a thousand degrees
Fahrenheit or so and now you have this
perfect heat exchange medium so it's a
great medium for collecting them and for
collecting the neutrons but now it's a
great medium for heat exchange so you
could run a generator and that's what we
do so that's how it works but it sort of
looks like this in real life and you can
see the salt flowing by it actually
floats flows pretty slowly I just want
you to know that's a gigawatt engine so
that you know it looks big on one scale
but this is the scale of the NIF right
and it's a 1.4 million just to say
gigawatt is 1.4 million horsepower it
has no carbon you know our brain carbon
and there's no co2 and what are you
using water you know the hydrogen from
water and in fact one liter of heavy
water so that pitcher you know is
equivalent to two million gallons of
gasoline it's a phenomenal thought you
know that's why we love hydrogen now
this isn't like hydrogen in your car
right you know hydrogen cars this is
very different that's a chemical
hydrogen process in fact when I first
briefed the governor about the
governador about this he said edy that I
wish I could do his accent but I can't
he said what's the difference between
your hydrogen and my hydrogen and I said
well governor you could take your Hummer
and drive it you know your hydrogen
powered Hummer and drive it from San
Francisco to LA you know I could take
seven million of them and
that distance so it's sort of a really
different scale so just keep that
picture in your mind's eye in fact think
about the alternative if you had like
it's hard to think of a 1.4 million
horsepower engine
but life avoids around 7 million tons of
co2 per gigawatt year or a thousand
megawatt year so how big is San
Francisco since we live here right it's
a thousand megawatt City sort of it's a
little bit smaller that's what we're
buried so 7 million tons of co2 per year
so this is a very large number so what
is nice about this you know laser
inertial fusion energy is a separable
system you know that means that the
laser the targets the fusion engine and
the balance of plant where is where we
make electricity and ship it out can
sort of all be developed pretty much
independently of each other and then
what's really nice about that is that
the balance of plant sort of exists we
don't have to reinvent that it's
everywhere you go right the fusion
chamber has some material issues but
they seem manageable the laser people
always bring up and the targets have to
be cheap so that's the challenge you
know and I'll talk about that in a
second
[Music]
that's that's a 50 Hertz laser 50
kilowatts burning through a half-inch of
steel and that that hole is this big
right so when people say you can't make
a laser do this that's not exactly right
we just showed that the question is can
you make it economically right that's
really the question this is a
semiconductor this will be a
semiconductor driven laser and I'm gonna
show you something which you're gonna
have a hard time seeing but this is can
anyone see this right this is a laser
bar that would be used to drive this and
if you looked at it carefully you would
in here from Silicon Valley you would go
I know how to make that right you know
this is the kind of technologies we'll
be able to use and what's good about
that is we get to ride on the backs of
other technologies and make this happen
this is a target that's us that's a kind
of a fancy-looking target remember
that's a centimeters less than a 1/2
inch and question is it's an R&D target
could you make those cheap and we want
to make them for under 50 cents right
and so we think we can you know here's
our goal you know our goal is 25 cents
or so and for California where you would
need about five billion a year it sounds
like a big number right and the
tolerance on them is around 50 microns
remember your hair is about a 100
microns or so and you know there's a lot
of things that humans make at billions a
year in fact it's more than this list
you know Lego blocks everyone uses those
are 2 billion a year
they're the most precision thing that
you'll ever use in your normal life
and I the reason that you can your kids
can play with your Lego blocks is
because they're so precise they don't
wear alright it's kind of an amazing
thought and they're free you know and if
people say what is it will you spend
that weight you spend for Lego blocks is
to market them and chip them you know to
make them is essentially free right
except if you have to use oil to do it
right you know milspec bullets this is
an interesting number there's like
around 10 billion of those made every
year it's almost 2 for every one of us
right and you know they have specs that
are around there similar to what we're
looking at and they're bigger and
heavier and have more material and
they're made for about 20 cents and I
also think if you look at soda cans
which is big but they're made for a
penny or so so the whole idea of making
billions of things that these costs is
very possible and there's no there's all
kinds of developments and
nanotechnologies and the like that are
going to drive this down right so here's
our roadmap for an it for life you know
we want to get ignition in quote unquote
2010 you know we say 2010 to 2012 I'm
rounding you know this is when we think
we'll be in a situation that will show
that we can get more energy out than we
put in it's gonna be an exciting day
when that happens right we think in the
2020 time period if there's a will and
I'm going to talk about that we have the
way to build a engineering demo so that
people and the utilities and others
could judge whether this is a part of
our collective energy future you know a
carbon-free energy future we think
economical one you know that's based on
technologies that will inevitably get
better over time you know because
they're technologies were doing and if
that were true we think in the 2030 to
2050 period we could become a part a
major part of the global energy society
which is the time that you saw that
challenge arises can we get into it can
we get to a low-carb could be a part of
it low
Carbon future so where are we
we've talked to serious people you know
we're a bunch of brainiacs at the lab
you know and we're trying to reach out
to people who can judge these things
better than we can
so we've talked to the CEOs
vice-president levels of many utilities
like pinnacle West PG&E mid-america
nuclear Management constellation
Dominion and Southern Cal Edison didn't
get on this exelon you know these are
have about sixty five percent of the
ratepayers in the in the country and
they're kind of excited about it in fact
if you can get a CEO to come out for a
day in fact a couple of them have come
out for more than a day to hear about
this and talk about it it's a sign that
the you know serious people with serious
you know money and serious ideas in this
are interested there's a lot of other
people who have come out to from people
like Bill Gates you know you always have
to drop names but many other politicians
and business people and you know people
like Stewart you know who are
environmentally driven who are thinking
about our future and how to make it play
out because this is a challenge for all
of us but one of the things these people
ask is can you do it economically right
can you have market penetration at the
time they need is it operable and
maintainable is there a supply chain
does it fit into the licensing structure
and energy policy we have stories for
all these not for tonight what I want to
talk about though is the economics you
know there's an interesting view graph
it's a blank but it sort of tells the
story of how the world looks you know if
you're a rate payer this is what you
care about you know this is you know
dollars per kilowatt hour this is a dime
for a kilowatt hour you like that you
know a nickel you love right up here you
know you're not so sure but this is what
banks and utilities like to understand
you know this is the capital intensities
the dollars per kilowatt of capacity
you know now I could put this dollars
per megawatt or gigawatt of capacity
which is the kind of plants people would
then you would say this is 20 billion
dollars 25 billion dollars right if you
were talking about dollars per gigawatt
so that's what people are thinking about
so I want to go put some numbers up so I
think these are important things to
consider now and you know people are a
little bit surprised when I show these
you know that's photovoltaic solar right
for usable capacity it's kind of an
amazing number you know a gigawatt of
that sort of cost 25 billion dollars
right now right most people don't know
that this is a heavily subsidized
government subsidized activity that's
why people can buy that they didn't have
that it'd be very hard and remember you
know it's only on during the day not at
the night and the reason it works at all
is because there's all that base power
that you're adding and adding in into
when you can and subtracting from when
you can't to do this well offshore wind
is an interesting idea you know it's
supposed to be on most of the time but
it's pretty expensive it's really the
reliability and maintainability issues
of you know windmills that are 500 feet
high in 500 feet of water it's a pretty
hard problem you know from an
engineering point of view the other ones
are like water reactors that's nuclear
which is you know from the point of view
of cost you know is really good and from
the point of view of carbon is great but
the trouble is it keeps inching up you
know it inches to the right you know in
terms of capital costs so that's why
President Obama has the loan guarantee
program for utilities to build new
nuclear so it's a real hard problem
there's fossil fuels you know the way
you do it is carbon capture and
sequestration if you could drag the cut
the carbon out of you know the the flues
as it was coming out and put it back on
the ground liquefy it and pump it
underground you could do something right
but it's a volatile and it's not a well
developed
and uses lots of water so a lot of
places cannot use it right now but all
of these can be part of our energy mix
the question is what about life well
we've done a lot of studies about life
and it's kind of interesting sort of
looks between fossil fuels and light
water reactors and capital costs and
also in the cost of electricity now you
could say to me you've never built
anything how do you know how much it
costs right well we built an if we know
how much that costs and we know what
these what these dials are gonna cost
because there's a lot of models for
semiconductors and we think we
understand targets and there are the
building's stuff we we think we get this
is probably reasonably accurate you know
the thing that's interesting about it is
it's not a carbon producer at all it
avoids all carbon and that's really an
important issue because if you look at
what would happen if the United States
deployed you know 700 of them like we
talked about in filling that wedge which
is not hard to do you're talking about
starting in 2030 doing like one a year
and going up to 2040 one a month you
could sort of displace a hundred and
forty gigatonnes of carbon dioxide
compared to coal by the way those are
called wedges if any of you are in this
world that's a lot of wedges there's 30
wedges on earth right and you know if
this were more displaced this was a part
of our worldwide community and again
this this this putting this in fits
models for how plants are coming offline
and how we could put them online you
could have a big story here and remember
the cost of carbon is expected to be
around $100 a ton mitigating carbon or
buying off carbon so just to go over it
a hundred and forty billion tons is 14
trillion dollars so you could start
paying for this on its own it could pay
its way into the future
and you know that would change also a
lot of stuff about how to do this you
know if you think that's what the cost
of carbon will be which I think a lot of
people do in fact if you look at how
much would it cost to develop it you
know it if you assume twenty billion
dollars in R&D and development funding
through 2030 so to build the first two
plants right and you know develop them
and build them and you discounted the
value of that coal of that carbon
dioxide you're talking about $1 per
tonne so this is an insurance policy
that you would like to have you know you
spend $1 to avoid $100 forever so it's a
really interesting idea so the RD&D cost
you know over time are essentially zero
so let me just finish my talk you know
you know laser inertial fusion energy
it's sustainable its carbon free it's
not geopolitical it's safe its modular
its compact you could do a relatively
rapid development path it uses our
infrastructure what's really cool about
it it will always accept evolutionary
improvements in semiconductor technology
performance at targets and we don't have
to invent our own industry to do it we
use other industries that already exist
this is sort of you know too good to be
true all of these things coming together
you know we're about to find out how
good it is to be true you know we think
we have a story we think it's well
analyzed we have a lot to do to make
this all happen but you know look what
the choice is you know we are at a
Knothole in the energy environmental
challenge right you know I think this
sweep of history from a hundred years
ago to a hundred years from now it's
kind of an interesting thought you know
I have to thank the long now foundation
for getting me to rethink how I think
right and you know when I thought about
this what was you know what was a
hundred years ago we had on
I show up you know this was this was
really the beginning of modern science
as we know it you know we had quantum
mechanics was developing you know
everything we know about our
post-industrial revolution age was
changing literally my grandparents were
in using horse and buggy right it's a
fact when they were born you know this
is when this period was changing you
know in 1950 1960 50 years ago you know
the quantum revolution was on in
integrated circuits were happening that
laser was developed and here we are you
know in 2010 on the verge of proving
that we can get ignition gain we're
using hydrogen as a fuel with lasers and
what do we have to do you know do we
have a future that's bright and clean a
hundred years from now or not you know
cat how do we get through here this is
sort of this not hole that we face now
it looks like it's in 2030 but it's
really right two-second right you know
this is our this is our challenge and
this is our responsibility so you know
what's what's your role so I didn't come
here just to talk you know I'm here
recruiting and signing up no so you know
we have a clear societal need and when I
talk about societal need talking about
you know our responsibility as stewards
of our own planet and you know there's
several solutions I don't want to come
across that there's only one but they
have to be worked on we have to look at
the options and scientists and
technologists can give you a lot of
choices and I hope this is one that you
will go home and talk about but it won't
get done because we did this right you
know there are issues of policy funding
industrial commitment communication you
know personal commitment to our own
future and our children's future in our
grandchildren's future but the problem
is we live in a world that had that is
let me tell you there's a brick wall
here and everyone knows it
right you know which is short-term
vision unwillingness to invest in what
are obvious problems vested interests
that have different points of view
you know preconceptions about what can
and can't work sometimes called
skepticism you know and apathy I think
the amazing part of the Gulf of Mexico
is so far nothing has happened it's sort
of scratching the back of your head
right
but it hasn't [ __ ] hat we haven't woken
up to it and I also again remember
that's going that a very small rate
compared to the amount of oil were we're
burning in the United States I think
that life you know if we had a lot of
friends of life if they were talking to
their politicians if they were talking
to each other you know if they wanted to
learn more about it come to our website
so lasers llnl gov you know they made a
story you know could make this happen no
so we can't do it on our own we need
your help and you know we can't if we do
that I think we can jump that wall and
or if we're a conic quantum-mechanically
thinking tunnel through that wall and
not even touch it right so when I look
at this is their fusion in our future I
love this picture because you know
that's four billion barrels of oil four
million barrels of oil coming out of the
Gulf right when I show this to kids I
say where do you see your energy future
of course they see the tanker and then I
say look real carefully and takes them a
long time to see the Sun and then I say
what's burning in the Sun water right so
Fusion is in our future can we make it
happen let's invent the future together
thank you for your time
we're gonna raise the screen when you
sit over here who's your competition
have you been around some of the other
laser facilities not everybody's using
other fusion facilities not everybody's
using lasers right so there's you know
there's three types of fusion to first
order on earth in the universe right
there's gravitational fusion that's when
you look up in the sky you know just
gravity squashing together gasses until
they get real hot and burn
there's laser inertial fusion which is
where we you know create that oven and
smash them together and there's
something else called magnetic fusion
magnetic fusion is a very different
process and it's not it's not high
density it's very low density but very
hot and you build a magnetic bottle so
this very hot gas never touches the
walls of the chamber because if it did
first of all it would cool and stop stop
the reaction would stop immediately so
there's a there's this is a big
community worldwide and magnetic fusion
energy is being demonstrated hopefully
in the 2025 to 2030 time period at a
facility called eater or ITER
while they eat at or if you're in
Colorado ants where it's being built and
right now it's going through sort of a
little bit of a rough period you'll be
reading about that in the near future
their goal is to build this facility and
have it operational in the mid to
late-20s so those are the possibilities
you know we hope to show that capability
in the next couple of years versus the
next you know 20 so that's a slight
difference there's outfits like I think
there's one in Vancouver that is trying
to do a pulsed version of fusion yeah
there's a company called general fusion
in Vancouver it's a small private
company they have some ideas about how
to do it I I wasn't in Vancouver - at
Ted maimings Ted maimings you know
the inventor of the laser his widow
Kathleen had a sort of a party you know
the weekend of the 50th demonstration
and I met some of those people and
they're enthusiastic I'll say that but I
think they have a lot of work to do one
question here from Gordon would be
clarifying for people compare and
contrast Fusion and fishing for energy
purposes okay so you know Fusion you
know there's you know if you look at the
periodic table right you know you have
one corner you have the little baby you
know atoms which are hydrogen right and
then on the other side you have the big
honker like uranium and uranium is
fissile material and it's nucleus is so
big you know it hardly stays together
now it actually stays together for
billions of years but it's sort of
liquidus and every once in a while
quantum mechanically it comes apart it
fissions splits and you get energy out
that way if you put enough of it
together and it's enriched you know when
its fission's you can take the neutrons
that come out and hit some other ones
like that and split them again and you
have that famous chain reaction and if
you build the fission power plant and
you just keep it right at the edge which
is not hard to do you can just keep
energy coming out Fusion is the opposite
we take you know hydrogen atoms and
smash them together for very short time
so this one only lasts for billions
trillions of a second I have to tell you
if you built a fusion power plant like
life and it was running ten times a
second for a year you know all of you
should know there's pi times 10 to the 7
seconds in a year does everyone know
that about you know so that's pi times
10 to the 8th shots and it's on for 10
picoseconds so that means the plant
would actually be putting out energy for
3 thousandths of a second per year so
it's never on but
but you collect the energy in the salt
and that sort of keeps it you know
thermally thermally constant so that's
the difference one is a coming apart
process ones that going together process
one is cannot sustain itself one can't
sustain itself so you're hoping for
ignition this year or early next year
and then that the roadmap says ten years
to the prototype of an actual fusion
reactor that supplies electricity the
most of that ten years will be spent
doing what okay so you know remember
this is if there's a will there's away
right you know the beginning will be you
know convincing people this is the right
thing to do but there are several things
you have to do you know there's
engineering issues and technical issues
that have to be done and facilities
ation of like certain parts of the
semiconductor industry and other and
other associated industries building
partnerships to go ahead and do this and
put it together it ends up the scale of
these projects like the NIF you know
it's sort of 10 years right for the
first one just 10 to 12 just the way it
is that's the inertia that's the arc of
starting you know designing building
commissioning getting operational just
the way these kind of projects run our
goal is you know once we get going is
that you could sort of turn went on in a
very modular way in two years you know
that's sort of ambitious but right now
if you order up a 500 megawatt natural
gas generator you know you can sort of
turn it on in two years and and we think
of building a fact a laser factory
factory in a target factory factory in a
parts factory factory so you just ship
it in you know on normal trucks and
things like that
now mmm so I recall when I was visiting
there he said that this thing doesn't it
scales up pretty well but it probably
doesn't scale down much below of one
gigawatt reactor yeah I talked about
that fusion likes to go big right and
that you know the way the the energy
works out you know if you
make it if you go from one gigawatt to
one-and-a-half gigawatts the energy jobs
pretty the cost of energy drops pretty
nicely so you can make it small but you
pay for it but we have some new ideas
that we're in fact we're gonna have a
meeting about it actually tomorrow I
think it 10:30 you know to talk about
some ideas that might make it much more
modular than some of the ideas we have
now people sort of like in some parts
250 to 500 megawatts is sort of you know
chunkiness of systems right now and they
don't like much bigger than one and a
half gigawatts because it sort of
distorts the grid you know how the grids
look like so we're looking at you know
you know how we could scale it down and
still maintain the cost well you've got
a three point five billion dollar 12
acre facility scaling down sounds like
you know how to do oh well I I actually
want to talk about that you know when
you guys and gals buy energy don't don't
think that it doesn't cost billions of
dollars to put in gigawatts right
because it does and and there's no doubt
about that that's what I was showing
about that curve you know you saw from
25 billion dollars a gigawatt to 3
billion dollars a gigawatt this is an
R&D facility it's not a production
facility and a lot of things came along
for that three and a half billion
dollars we revolutionize the glass and
optics business of the world certainly
our country we change the nature of many
aspects of control systems and and
database systems and many other things
so it really is a part of our natural
competitive competitive nasai
that as part of our strategic defense
program and also our look at the
universe you know we're gonna be able to
do experiments where we can you know
simulate what's going on in the stars
and supernovas inside planets you know
right in the NIF so it has a broad set
of uses so I think was a good deal for
three and a half billion but we we
worked hard
and we remember we work for the
taxpayers and we are taxpayers and we
take that job very seriously say more
about the national defense aspect I
assume that this kind of money coming
into operation like this particularly at
Lawrence Livermore is not going to be
just about energy correct so you know
when President the first president Bush
stopped nuclear testing right which is
now 19 years ago almost there was a
major debate about well how would you
ensure the stockpile our nuclear
stockpile would be safe effective and
actually we would know how it worked
over time because it ages and people
always use this example if someone said
here's a plane and it's at the end of
the runway and you can't start it you
know ever you know and 20 years from now
someone says we'd like to see if it
works but we're gonna check it by having
you fly it you know would you get on it
now the goal here is not to coerce to
use these weapons but we do have a
responsibility through treaties around
the world as the deterrence you know and
protect the free world and much of it
you know with the assuredness that our
stockpile works so the NIF is a part of
that capability it has you have the
ability to do conditions that exist you
know in in this in the stockpile without
testing and President Obama has just
actually spoken to this issue and
reaffirmed how important this is now is
our stockpile of mostly fusion weapons
or efficient weapons or does that very
relation to you the research you're
doing well I think you all should go to
Wikipedia and read it you know our
stockpile is a combination of fusion and
fission weapons and so this lets you do
research on the fusion aspect of that
yeah and and all aspects of it know what
are the astronomers want to do with your
equipment okay so this is actually what
I think is
and to me some of the most cool stuff
you know you know when you look up at
the planets that we are finding right
now remember we were nine planets and
then we were eight planets you know poor
Pluto right right now we're sort of 400
planets and the Kepler tells the Kepler
space telescope is out there right now
and I know from some of my friends in
Berkeley and other places that some very
exciting announcements are coming out
probably this fall and and it's a very
interesting thing as we find more and
more of these planets we thought that we
understood our solar system but now our
solar system looks very strange right
and we can create the conditions that
exist inside the earth you know where
you know inside the earth the iron that
we have on earth does not look like the
iron that it has inside the earth
because of the pressure is under or in
Jupiter or in Neptune or in the
supergiant earth planets that are being
found and hopefully people you know will
use the NIF to unravel the secrets we're
also gonna be doing supernova studies
you know little tiny one so instead of
looking up in the sky insane looking at
something that happened two billion
years ago you could say we'd like to
build a tiny supernova you know on April
28th you know at 3 in the afternoon
bring all your diagnostics and not only
that we'd like to play with it so on
April 29th we'd like to build a slightly
different one and really just sort of
unravel that physics so this will be the
first time we can do experimental
astronomy you know on earth it's kind of
a great idea
it's a sign of a good talk we'll get
lots of questions some of them are kind
of technical basically looking at what
are the sort of limiting factors here so
one question for max Ferretti is how do
you deal with radioactivity that results
from fusion on a large scale you have to
wind up burying the chamber are the you
know targets once they've been used or
what's the issue
with them and so on okay so what happens
when when you you know ignite a target
you know you get neutrons that come out
and neutrons can interact with a lot of
materials and it's called to activate
them so if certain materials absorb a
neutron they can become radioactive and
then they'll split and there they'll
fission right and give off you know
radioactivity so that that sort of could
be a problem you know in some senses but
what we do is we use materials that are
generally resistant to that kind of
activation problem there's a lot of
special materials that have been
invented for the nuclear industry and
the fusion industry over the years and
there's tremendous work in it to bring
that down to a very low level and make
it short-lived so there will be some
like in the first wall is the first
place remember you know you have to have
those neutrons go through the first wall
before they get to the solve that wall
can become slightly radioactive you know
with lifetimes of years and you would
just at that time use it's called
shallow ground storage you know and or
open cat or cast storage and then after
a few years you would be it would be
returned to its normal condition so is
that the extent of the radioactive waste
stream basically coming out of that is
our hope and we're studying that quite a
bit right yeah that's our goal remember
we're not putting in in anything that
has long lifetimes and we're trying not
to have anything nearby that could
detain law long lifetimes a couple
people are curious about you mentioned
gold in there is gold a limiting factor
it's an expensive material now gold is
just the limiting factor and keeping
physicists happy we use a baton in one
of those targets you know right now we
use about a hundred milligrams of gold
so it sort of doesn't cost very much
money and but in the real in a real
target you're thinking about as I said
billions per year you would never use
gold you wouldn't use gold for a lot of
reasons first of all it's expensive it's
hard to you know use and and and it's
not very helpful because it's melting
point is high so what would happen is
you you
blow this up you know it get really hot
and it would fly apart and then it would
condense in places that were cold and
sort of forms stalactites and
stalagmites you know you don't want that
so what we're thinking about a lot is
sort of led targets no lead is you know
almost as good as gold is in performance
not exactly as good it's a few percent
worse but it has a very low melting
point better yet going back to that
other question it doesn't get
radioactive and you can keep using it
over and over and over again there's a
vast I mean that the technological
sublime aspect that visiting you're seen
as besides the target chamber which is
pretty chaotic in its own right but the
vast array of laser apparatus that's
involved is that all is a given or is
there a way to make that more efficient
somehow yeah you known if you have to
understand no matter even though it's
the the most you know advanced laser on
earth is sort of built on 1990s
technology right you know because it's
sort of that's the inertia in the system
once you start designing it to procure
it and build it so it goes back into the
90s so we have ideas that will take that
laser that laser Bay you know you that
was almost four hundred feet long and
put it into 30 feet and have about ten
times more ten to twenty times more
efficient use of electricity and turning
electricity into light and so our goal
is that it struck a bowl right there you
can put it on an 18-wheeler and drag it
around not the whole thing but each part
and actually the our goal for a gigawatt
plant would be it'd be smaller than the
NIF now the NIF is you know people say
it's the biggest laser but I always
point out it's smaller than Costco right
and compared to Ikea it's somewhere in
the bathroom section
question here from Roger Smith on when
you get ignition or if you get ignition
but we all say when let's see basically
the efficiency of that the event the
energy out versus energy in okay so the
our goal is you know ignition is defined
as the following
you know formal the formal scientific
definition when you get as much energy
out as you put in then you have a
burning target you know if you're a real
physicist right when you get about
fifteen percent as much out as you put
in it's actually started to burn right
but no one wants to have that argument
so they just say one our goal in the
first few years to get 10 to 20 times
more out than we put in any sign of the
advances in the tea kettle aspect you
mentioned that we're still doing James
Watts steam engines here well yeah
actually they're really you know we make
a joke but you know James Watt was you
know when he did his work you know he
was converting energy at less than a
tenth of a percent you know and we're
sort of looking at 50% right now and
people are have ideas to get higher
conversion efficiencies but this is a
thermodynamic problem you know mother
nature you know everything is running
downhill you know once anytime you touch
energy and change it to another form you
lose ya can't stop that and so 50% is a
good number you know we you know we talk
about the plans with 65% but those I
think are pretty far-fetched for the
next ten years you know new materials
will come by that's what how this this
is how this field goes forward that you
can run them hotter and the the larger
the temperature difference between the
input and the output you know the more
energy efficiency you can get so if you
could run it hotter will get more later
there's kind of a long now question from
a Stephen deal 50 years well we look at
your life technology as being as crude
as first generation nuclear
do you have any sense of what
second-generation fusion might look like
well my answer is I hope so right you
know right now you have to understand
the targets we are using are sort of
very conservative targets in the sense
that you know we have experience with
them we can can we think we can
calculate them with the kind of
computers we have we think we can
understand their performance and we're
not pushing on that agenda very hard
we're just pushing to prove that you can
do it you know like if the Wright
brothers said I'm not gonna try to fly a
plane until I have a jet engine you know
we would have waited a long time at the
same time we have all kinds of ideas
that have that have been around and are
growing that show abilities you know on
paper to get as much as 10 times more
gain from targets that we have now
certainly you know the drivers will
inevitably get better they just can't
help themselves they you know will with
or without our help and so we think that
you know in 50 years this this will look
pretty crude and by the way if you look
at the lasers we were building 20 years
ago they look really crude right so
that's just gonna happen which raises
the question is 50 years of laser
development at at Lawrence Livermore 50
more years of wage development are
lasers proliferating as as you suggest
with transistors to be at the core of
all sorts of things lasers have you know
lasers are so fundamental to all of your
lives every day every time you get on
the phone you know every time you turn
on your DVD every time you turn on your
TV all you know all your cars are
manufactured and well you know cut and
welded with lasers lasers are just so
ubiquitous in your life that no one
knows they're there you know that's the
transition they have made and it's going
to it's going to be I've read you know a
trillion dollar business by 2015 so it's
a part of the world economy
and now remember photons are so good
right they have no mass they have no
charge but they carry energy and
momentum and by the way they also go to
be coherent so if they're just too cool
there's a question from Paul Hawken how
can you provide affordable clean energy
when datura infusion reactors are
neutronic and must be serviced by robots
say again I just missed it how can you
produce affordable clean energy when de
triomphe eugene reactors hard neutronic
and must be serviced by robots
okay so mmm first of all we're not
two-tier we're not doing deuterium
deuterium systems doing DT but that's
not for deuterium tritium right you know
that's not your main to your question
you know your question is a good
question when you do do you do do this
it'll sort of run itself and you know
for years at a time but at some point
you'll have to maintain them not the
laser right and not the final optics and
not to balance a plant none of that
stuff will have any radioactivity but
the target chamber wall will be as I
said gets slightly hot so what you have
to do is you know move it out and we
have an idea about how to do this which
just put it on a railroad track inside
inside the building take it out let it
sit there for a little while and and
then put a new one in and a little wild
is depending on how much shielding you
want to put around it before you
robotics are from hours to weeks so this
is not a big issue with respect to how
long it takes and also this is kind of
small you know you know as I said if
that target chamber were ten meters in
diameter like NIF it's kind of a small
item to maintain and this is of course
an engineering problem that we have to
take on and we take you know there's a
lot of experience in the world with this
kind of robotic system the last question
from Robin what's the gating factor in
fusion research now is it funding
understanding infrastructure or
something else in other words what
can most help to make this move along I
really think this is a great question I
think that is the last question I think
I sort of tried to say I think it's all
of you right you know how do we feel
about what we say about our environment
in our economic future and what our
children going to deal with and I think
that this is a relatively high payoff
and with respect to the risk incredible
return on investment with respect to our
future and I think right now when we
look at it it's funding the demo plant
right now presumably we get ignition in
the next couple of years you know it's
gonna be all over the newspapers
everyone's gonna be you know talking
about it you know very excitedly I
always ask this question is is this
Apollo 17 yeah right some people think
the Apollo program was a big success you
know I grew up it changed my life some
people say well what happened right
that's the moment we're gonna reach are
we gonna have a future vision you know
and be able to jump on it and that's
because we're gonna have mobilized our
politicians and we're gonna have you
know word-of-mouth and grassroots
efforts making this happen or not I
think that's that's the big challenge
and that's why I'm here today so it
sounds like the prototype is not the
current building and apparatus you have
the prototype is a separate building a
separate apparatus specifically not for
research but for energy and it will cost
some of them out to make that prototype
well I would say it in two ways you know
this is the performance prototype it
shows all the capability of the game to
show that the basic principles are
correct right and it will show over
years that you can do better and better
it will always be that research machine
but the one that you know utilities have
to then sign up for you know you need
one more step mm-hmm and that's the one
we're talking about so that it would be
that's a live demo right and in your
view that would be another facility you
would build at Lawrence
or actually you know I I don't get to
decide where that's built right you know
you know that's will be a you know a
debate you know a lot of people of
where's the best place to put it you
know I'd always loved it I loved it to
be in the Bay Area but it's not my
choice alone that's again wolf decide
together what our chances of it being
somewhere outside the US some other
country saying we're gonna proceed now
okay right now you know we are the clear
world leaders in this act every aspect
of this activity you know I traveled to
China about a year ago and I was with
the deputy chief of the Chinese Academy
of Sciences you know and I he was asked
they're building a nip
you know also Zhang Wang for we're in
Hong Kong province right and and you
know he was asking me how was going
which is sort of kabuki because he knows
that what's going but anyway you know
but we sit there and and I'm telling
them and and and I said and how it sure
is going he says sometimes it's good to
be second and I take that you know
comment very seriously I was just in
Japan last week you know the Japanese
are interested maybe imparting with us
and I hate to say it two weeks ago I was
or three weeks ago I fought I lost track
I was in Europe and I was in Great
Britain and France
this is attracting a lot of attention
and you know it would break my heart if
it were somewhere if it were built for
the first time somewhere else you know
and it's all my intention to make it a
part of our national portfolio and
hopefully orbit intention also well that
leads to one more question because with
nuclear people are saying well there's
this weaponization capability and we
have to have these fuel banking
workarounds and so on if United Arab
Emirates is going to have nuclear then
they should buy the fuel from somebody
else and send it back to them
suppose United Arab Emirates it's just
the kind of thing I might do I beg abuse
is okay we're going to have
fusion reactor do we care that there's
any kind of weapons application the
answer the answer is just to say this is
I'm not going to give my opinion now
this is the opinion of the State
Department the Department of Energy and
others Fusion is not considered a
proliferation technology you know if you
wanted to break out to use this for
weaponization or to make you know
fissile materials and you thought this
was the way you would have failed the IQ
test this is people are doing it without
this without this trouble you know so
the answer is it's not considered a
proliferation technology I think the
real issue is the one we talk it's a
national competitiveness issue of Abu
Dhabi or somebody else you know we're to
try to buy this capability you know or
develop it on their own I think would be
real hard for them you know they don't
have the infrastructure to do it but you
know I just would again this is our you
know we invented this you know we've
developed it it's a part of this I have
to say it you know it's a bay area story
you know everywhere you look around the
Bay Area this intellectual prowess
manufacturing prowess to pull this
together investment prowess you know
venture and the like so I think this
would belongs here very much and I hope
that someday you know hopefully while
I'm in live San Francisco is powered by
fusion and I hope 100 years from now
we've made the the switch to a fusion
society which is unlimited in energy
clean energy so the next 10,000 years
are kind of a nice 10,000 years bring it
on
thank you thank you
[Music]
hold on thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you